camps in the community  jazz will get a couple in a row at home  after this one after tonight in fact 9  out of 13 at home this one's knocked  around taken by russ big rebound by the  lakers  [Applause]  i got elaine i'm being me i'm going to  attack the basket he takes it the  distance and gets the foul and one so  he's at the line for a possible  three-point play  what a sequence here by the lakers  and they're up seven with 40 seconds to  play  rush free throwing tonight he's made his  only attempt  russ with a dozen to go along with seven  rebounds three assists  he goes the distance we got a timeout  wow  what a sequence in the last 25-30  seconds as the lakers have an  eight-point advantage with 40 seconds  left to play